hi in this video I'm going to talk about
biotransformation biotransformation
means transformation of drug and also it
could be thought as a detoxification of
drugs so biotransformation reactions
takes place in the liver and there are
two phases of biotransformation reaction
phase 1 and phase 2 biotransformation
reaction so biotransformation reaction
not only take place in the liver
apart from liver it could take place in
lungs and also in intestine because some
enzyme in the intestine also take place
in biotransformation reaction but the
major reaction would take place in the
liver the cytochrome p450 system would
take a vital role in these power
transformation reactions so here we have
a human being so the main site for bio
transformation reaction would be its
liver its liver would be a main site for
the bio transformation reaction in the
liver first biotransformation reaction
would be done by microsomal enzyme
system microsomal enzyme so microsomal
enzyme would do two type of reaction
first step reaction would be oxidation
type reaction or we can say first step
would be the redox reaction and the
second step would be like conjugation
reaction conjugation reaction so our in
liver we also have non microsomal
enzymes non microsomal enzymes such as
we have alcohol dehydrogenase
which actually oxidized alcohol into
aldehyde acetaldehyde basically ethanol
to acetaldehyde so these are the two
basic enzyme system in the liver that
can detoxify drugs and bio transform
transform drugs so main goal of the bio
transformation would be to make the drug
more soluble so that it could be easily
excreted by the urine so apart from this
lever we have extrahepatic microsomal
enzymes which also toxify x' drugs so
here we have a drug here we have a drug
say for instance it is aspirin aspirin
is a very popular drug it's the N side
that means non-steroidal
anti-inflammatory drug and these aspirin
would be transformed bio transformed
inside the liver into our more soluble
form so that it could be easily or
excreted in the urine so in the first
phase of reaction that means the phase 1
reaction would be hydroxylation in this
case would be hydroxylation and after
hydroxylation as you can see a hydroxyl
group is attached in the esteem chain so
this hydroxyl group would make these
intermediate a little bit more soluble
after hydroxylation what would happen
the second second phase of the
biotransformation reaction would be our
conjugation type of reaction so UDP
glucose Ron I'd transference
would transfer a blue chloride group
into the whole explain this aspirin
sidechain and as you can see there are
many polar groups here so it is highly
soluble and it could be easily excreted
into the urine okay back to the phase 1
reactions
what we have we have a drug and after
biotransformation in this drug we would
have a Oh H group which is more
water-soluble and easily excludable so
for each group so what will happen
molecular oxygen would be used molecular
oxygen would be used to hydroxylate this
truck and this reaction would take place
by the help of the enzyme cy p450 that
means cytochrome p450 this cytochrome
p450 enzymes are found in liver mainly
in liver hepatocytes in the smooth
endoplasmic reticulum so these molecular
oxygen would be broken down and one
oxygen would be utilized to bio
transform the drug and other would form
water and electron would be provided in
this reaction by the help of NADPH and
as you remember these NADPH comes from
the pentose phosphate pathway so NADPH
is basically converted into nadp+ and
this is the phase one by transformation
reaction of this particular drug and it
has a H group now it's more soluble so
let's see in details how these
biotransformation reactions of phase 1
are catalyzed by these cytochrome p450
enzymes
so these cytochrome p450 enzymes are
basically team containing enzymes so i'm
just representing cytochrome p450 as
just two circle so I'm writing p450 and
it has Fe three-plus inside its heme
group now we have our drug which have
our age group first step of this
reaction would be drug would be
associated with these enzyme system so
here we have
our p450 with Fe three-plus and now we
have our drug and these enzyme complex
now we need electron and if this thing
would great gain electron from NADPH
after gaining electron this Fe
three-plus would be converted into Fe 2
plus and the whole conjugate would
remain the same after this reaction what
happened molecular oxygen would come
into the picture so molecular oxygen
would get associated with these whole
complex so I'm just noting p450 p450 and
here we have a fee but in a plus 2 form
and we have our molecular oxygen and
here our second set of electron is
required and again this electron would
come from NADPH and NADPH is generated
from the pentose phosphate pathway and
here we have the drug after gaining this
electron what would happen these enzyme
system would be regenerated and the
product would be hydroxylated drug so
this drug would be hydroxylated and also
water would be released so this
molecular oxygen o2 is actually one of
the oxygen is used to hydroxylation
reaction and another of oxygen is used
to produce the h2o so if you try to
summarize the reaction of our phrase 1
versus our phase two reactions so phase
one most important reaction is oxidation
and oxidation reactions are aided by mix
of mixed function oxidase and these mix
function oxidase takes important role in
oxidation reaction then we have
hydroxylation as we see in this example
we have hydroxylation reaction then
another thing could take place that is
hydrolysis hydrolysis means with the
help of water bond would be broken down
this type of reaction takes place for
esters very common for the local
anesthetics for Phase two
so these three are main reaction for
Phase one by transformation reaction and
as for Phase two reaction are concerned
first one type of reaction would be
glucuronidation de liquor row nine
nation as we have seen for aspirin the
second type of reaction could be
acetylation and for all the phase two
enzymes one thing is common these phase
two enzymes are actually transferase so
they transfer basically acetyl group or
do kronite group or it could be
methylation or it could be also
conjugation with gsh it could be
conjugation with
conjugation with gsh by nan microsomal
enzymes and also in phase 2 reaction the
important enzyme could be alcohol
dehydrogenase which can oxidize alcohol
so we can we learn that from p450 system
the phase 1 reaction is performed and
these p450s are mixed or oxide the the
p450s are mixed function oxidizes so we
also have in these phase 1 reaction
another type of reaction by Mao that is
monoamine oxidase we have a lot of
neurotransmitters which are mono Minds
like we have norepinephrine epinephrine
dopamine so these are metabolized by
these mouths one of em I oxidizes so the
key concepts of the bio transformation
is the goal of the bad transformation by
the liver is to make the drug more and
more soluble eyes soluble Ysabel form so
if the drug is more solubilized it is
more water soluble then it could be
easily excreted into the urine and if
the drug is not more solubilized the
drug could accumulate into the body and
it could build up toxicity so it's a
safety mechanism of our body and there
are basically two sets of reaction one
is phase one biotransformation reaction
another is phase two biotransformation
reaction so phase one is basically
oxidation or reductions hydroxylation
and hydrolysis some time and the phase
two reactions mainly involves the
glucuronidation the acetylation the
methylation and sometimes conjugation
with the GS h with the non microsomal
enzymes okay hope you liked it you have
enjoyed thanks for the video and please
subscribe